what's going on guys this is rob and
first things first i apologize if i'm
not excited as i normally am um i'm kind
of fighting off a bit of a cold i caught
it during thanksgiving
worst time to catch a cold
but uh let's talk about the hawkeye show
right specifically let's talk about uh
kingpin because i feel like this is the
one thing that a lot of people are
really curious about when it comes to
the show um a few things to point out
one i think echo is going to be really
really cool i think her story is going
to be a redemption story and i think
she's going to end up joining
hawkeye and kate bishop i think that the
old man who was murdered is actually the
father of echo i think that eleanor the
mother of kate bishop is going to turn
out to be madame mask and i think
kingpin is going to have a role in the
show but not until later on so uh that's
kind of my my predictions for the series
uh i didn't catch the episodes the first
two episodes which they released kind of
at the same time i didn't catch those
the night they came out um in fact i
actually didn't see those until about
friday so i was avoiding spoilers and
just not really reading up on anything
but like it was thanksgiving man right
cut me some slack i was flying on friday
i'm sorry on wednesday and then it was
thanksgiving thursday and then relaxing
on friday plus black friday shopping but
nonetheless uh here's the thing the show
itself was fun i get that a lot of
people are looking at hawkeye and
they're kind of like i mean there's a
show that exists right and you know
it's filler but we're just kind of
watching this until spider-man comes out
and then we'll keep on watching this
until the next thing comes out moon
night i think is what people are really
looking forward to and i'm really
looking forward to that too but the show
is fun i think the show had a great
blend of mystery and intrigue in the
first two episodes having said that um
for the character of madame mask this is
what's really interesting because
technically the character of eleanor
does exist in marvel comics but she's
kind of like a nega-sonic teenage
warhead-esque character right do you
guys remember in deadpool when you had
negasonic teenage warhead and everybody
wanted to know what her character was
about i made videos at that point in
time and i was like look guys i mean
there's really nothing on this girl
she's quite literally a girl you saw for
two panels before she and the 16 million
other mutants on jenosha were
obliterated by cassandra nova and a
bunch of sentinels right like there's
nothing on this girl you just you
literally see her long enough to see her
die and that's it eleanor is very much
the same way the involvement of eleanor
is limited in so far as she was believed
to have been dead and then it turned out
she was alive and she was actually
backing all the endeavors of madame mask
at the time basically the daughter of
count nefari if you don't know who she
is doesn't really matter this is not
comics explained so the point is she has
a very very short and limited run in the
hawkeye series as it was done by kelly
thompson and so with that in mind um i
would imagine that marvel would likely
take the character of eleanor as she
exists in the comics and bring her in as
the character of eleanor that you see in
the show but then also transform her
into madame mask right she's basically
just this really really cool character
that's one part mercenary one part just
like super intelligent member of the
criminal underworld and is most likely
competing with kingpin right now the
reason why i say that is because i think
that what might be going on here is the
father of echo is working for kingpin i
think that's kind of the thing that's
going on there um i don't know if echo
really has a hand in that but the reason
why i say that is because in the comics
the father of echo was actually a mob
enforcer who worked for kingpin and then
the way it was originally done in the
comics kingpin actually tricked echo
into believing that daredevil had killed
her dad and that's how you got the first
appearance of echo as well as her
initial conflict with daredevil you can
kind of switch some of those parts out
right so basically you have this
scenario unfold where you say that like
kingpin is actually the one responsible
for the death of ekko's father and then
echo at least where it gets to her quote
unquote by some mysterious source who
turns out to be kingpin later that it
was actually eleanor the mother of kate
bishop who killed her father and then in
turn uh now she's targeting hawkeye
right and then everything like the smoke
gets cleared and everything eleanor may
or may not be madame we have no real
idea but basically she's exonerated and
then like echo teams up with uh with
with kate bishop and with clint martin
and they go and they confront like the
kingpin wilson fisk so i think that if
you see him in this show you'll only see
him under a couple of different
circumstances the first circumstance
will be that he's like the main boss
right like the main bad guy that what
you're seeing here with like eleanor the
mother of kate bishop who looks like
she's kind of a villain that it's a ruse
right that like the the guy she's dating
who looks like a porn star from the 70s
that he's not really even a main villain
either right either that or is like he's
an enforcer working for kingpin who was
there to set it all up and make it look
like eleanor was the bad guy right
whatever the circumstance happens to be
but basically like wilson fisk is kind
of working behind the scenes and then
everything is cleared and like halfway
through the series then it's like okay
he's the main bad guy he's the person
they're going up against at the end of
the show the alternative to that is
kingpin's there but you don't see him
until like the last one or two episodes
and that kingpin's involvement in the
mcu is him just kind of appearing here
and appearing there right like he'll
have a role in the she-hulk show because
he's just the leader of the criminal
underworld and the guy that like
jennifer walters is trying to bust or
something along those lines and then
like the actual full-on kingpin acting
doing something of significance
involving the main star of a show
happens in daredevil where basically
it's kind of a return to the old like
netflix daredevil series where kingpin's
fighting matt murdock and they have
their whole thing however it is that
might unfold i could be entirely wrong
here i think marvel is most likely
playing the long game if you do see
kingpin face off against the the
hawkeyes in this show i think that would
be cool because it would give us an
indication of what he can do in
comparison to what we would refer to as
avengers because when you think of
hawkeye it's like i mean it's hawkeye
whatever but like if kingpin beats clint
martin you're like damn kingpin peed up
an avenger right and it's like okay
that's kind of a big deal right like
just the phrase he beat up an avenger is
not one that you just sort of tote
around lightly and so kind of building
him in in small little ways to where he
really feels like just this big imposing
figure by the time the new daredevil
series comes out it would be pretty
smart but let me know what you guys
think about that right i mean do you
think that kingpin is being built up
into this big thing do you think
kingpin's involvement is going to be
limited until the very very end and then
maybe it's a big fight between like
hawkeye and kate bishop maybe echo and
kingpin or something along those lines
let me know what you guys think right i
mean it's entirely possible echo is just
a straight-up villain and she's going to
be a villain for the whole show and they
kill her at the end i have no idea right
i have no real indication here i will
say this though i think echo is going to
be phenomenal in this show right those
you guys who don't know echo is
basically a girl that has what are in
effect the exact same abilities as
taskmaster tony masters right the
difference is that one she was not
designed to be just like tony masters
but a female version and two
she was designed to kind of compliment
daredevil in the sense that daredevil
was blind so she was created as a
initially a villain to daredevil who was
basically deaf they kind of shared that
disability and comment but her ability
to mimic the moves of others she only
has to see them once and so all she has
to do is see hawkeye punch once she's
got that punching style down right like
she could literally watch video footage
of like black panther t'challa fighting
bucky barnes right assuming that video
footage is captured and it's available
like from the news during like captain
america civil war right that whole big
huge skirmish and everything assuming
there's any video footage of that she'd
be able to fight just like t'challa
having only watched it one time that's
all it takes so literally fighting her
is fighting the entirety of the avengers
because what she could do would be very
similar to taskmaster in the black widow
movie albeit probably better where like
imagine that ekko's fighting like
hawkeye clinton barton and hawkeye kate
bishop and then in the middle of the
fight she starts fighting like captain
america and then she switches to black
panther and then she switches to
somebody else and somebody else and
somebody else is somebody else over and
over and over again even possibly
unidentified fighting styles that
actually belong to characters that we
haven't seen yet for example moon knight
right like she's encountered moon knight
or there's video footage of moon night
or something like that she sees it right
like when moon knight's learning how to
fight or the training sessions or
whatever she watches mark spectre fight
and then suddenly she's fighting like
marx specter just different things along
those lines right if there's video
footage of spider-man like fighting some
villain suddenly she's every bit as
agile as spider-man is like she's
flipping around and doing all kinds of
crazy stuff that's what makes echo so
dangerous so let me know what you guys
think about the the first couple
episodes of hawkeye so far are you
digging it are you kind of like that's
okay it's a show that exists right i
mean it's just something i'm watching to
fill time let me know what you guys
think but thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace